hello everybody my name is mozzarella
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mr. Musashi the game were
you you hang I wasn't done with my intro
here Oliver I'm not Johnny I'm mr.
Musashi I'm a mr. massage supplier I'm
Markus Sachi
I don't know what those mean Babbitt do
but get down Johnny you're great bastard
it's your old mate Oliver here listen
the noise is young and servi I know how
you love massage this right why does
your shirt say I heart I can only
imagine that's a goose or a duck that
doesn't look like any sort of chicken
I've ever seen so either you love [ __ ]
or you love duck or you love an oblong
piece of broccoli I'm not entirely sure
anyway I know you love massages right
right right okay boot up this app called
linger and it'll set it up on dates
willing to massage a turd like you get
those massages and be crowned that the
glorious mr. Musashi I'm unclear on the
purpose of this game what the [ __ ] is
happening here alright anyway you know
what I'll I'll get behind it so load
your man guns and start swiping for
dates oh I've been loading my man guns
as hard as I can you have the body and
the charming looks damn right I do if
it's one thing that markiplier got it's
the body and determined looks not the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you but you do have the best
wingman around me
oh it's Australian now don't go and lock
me down your Wonka that's Australian
right oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is that oh it's my
profile okay about me I'm a great
listener and in contact with my feelings
there's a sexy guy in my phone oh but
it's just me
Oh to get in touch with my inner joy
Bravo I lift and I can lift you up too
I'm a winner hail to the king baby hail
to the king I don't know what I'm doing
with my life anymore I need a hug well
that sounds like me all right then hang
on let me explore the rest of this all
right you know whatever it's fine I
can't tell who you are
I see living people you're damn right
you do
oh not enough experience pop whoo I oh
okay goodbye sorry I don't have enough
experience for you
social DSC share mr. Musashi annual new
dates are signing up cheer mr. Musashi
and you'll see them soon nope reel 19
okay Oh Jonny is in a fancy shrimp
restaurant his date just arrived hi my
name is real but everyone calls me to
tow I've been staring at you from
outside for a while wow you totally look
exactly like your real Inger pick I love
your flowing blonde hair hey girl you
are looking just wow straight to the
point huh where are you going with this
you have squishable boobs oh no
oh boy thanks I thought you were gonna
say something really stupid sorry that's
the only thing that I say hope you're
ready for a whole bunch of
disappointment on this lovely date of
ours why don't we grab something to eat
I'm kind of starving what would you like
ooh
t-bone steak baby straight to the bone a
shrimp sandwich a big fat just an onion
for me one whole onion
did you know onions have layers a lot
like an onion Oh hmm so I guess you'd
rather have stinky onion breath for me
ah just kidding ha
now I know you're interested in me ha
yeah you're so clever
ha ha got ya mailed ya not yet but soon
let's see I have more where that came
from
nice you know what I wanna get to know
you better
amid guys I'm in and I know the perfect
way to do it let's play a game it's
about knowing things oh god no I don't
know anything I'm [ __ ] give it a shot
truth or dare
it's not about knowing things truth me
nice
tell me what is your weirdest habit um I
like to buy giant bags of takis and then
I don't eat the takis itself I just lick
the powder off of there if there was a
way to get bulk powder if any of you
know how to get bulk takis powder let me
know I've wanted so badly I've got it
down to a science I know there's two
different factories that produce takis
there's an inferior version of takis and
then there's a superior version that's
extra powdery and tastes better anyway I
know this sponsor may takis sponsor may
I pretend I'm a cat and stare at people
cruise window you would love to see that
sounds creepy and cute at the same time
just like you baby just like you let's
switch now your turn okay truth or dare
I would say I choose truth
oh do you like massages I thought you
were never gonna ask let's whoa whoa
hell yeah what the [ __ ]
whoa oh [ __ ] you ready for the massage
of your life you ready oh oh oh it's oh
it's a rumbling so the hope I forgot to
mention the whole point in this game is
that you hook up your vibrator and
you're supposed to massage your neck you
know you're supposed to game alright
let's get into the massage whoa that's a
nice whoa whoo that actually is nice
it's pretty nice
controllers got a good rumble function
yeah it's nice I don't know I don't know
what I'm doing it my supposed to be
doing anything else here it's it
certainly is rumbly click click click it
click click click click click click
click click it click yeah that's a nice
massage right there oh oh that was a
tutorial okay no one told me what to do
at least I've got experience now I'll
just put my massager down yeah no I
didn't put it down my pants got a hug it
so let's wipe No
[Music]
I'm not sure what's going on here but
I'll go for it I guess you know hey we
like each other
mr. massage coming in coming in corded
make this look like I'm spinning in a
goddamn circle
[ __ ] okay Johnny meets with Nicole out
in the woods in the middle of the night
she wants to share with Johnny her
favorite hobby
[Music]
hi Johnny I'm so glad you made it this
means a lot to me I know it was a long
drive getting here but it'll be totally
worth it
just you wait oh are you excited to be
here
holy crap oh you know what
that's literally racist buddy I am a
werewolf but it's not like I go around
killing sheep and humping legs
well I hump some things but I don't want
to talk about it yet so maybe you can be
open-minded about this and maybe future
dates are sorry this is the first time
I've seen such a cute girl
haha got ya aw thanks my mom used to say
that too I take good care of my skin and
especially my hair I wash my hair with
I'm chicken
Oh being a werewolf in this world was
kind of hard especially this girl men
run away from me and women run away too
actually and man oh man I've had the
worst luck in dates what's been your
worst date so far oh my gosh so once I
dated this stable boy I need a pet duck
whoa emphasis on had duck you know my
scream the stable boy he was so girly
and that's why I was the worst date oh
I'd never blow it like that I have no I
might make a duck sound boffo [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my god what
the [ __ ]
yikes talk about a hairy situation
Johnny was attacked by a wolf rip man Oh
[Music]
krikey I reckon this wasn't my fault it
wasn't your fault
never read in any way what are you
supposed to be my wingman she was
probably gonna eat you but you know you
could have helped at least a little bit
let's try again huh all right burr burr
burr will [ __ ] okay so don't make a duck
sound I have no ducks left to give hey
that's awesome I have a feeling you
won't anyway that's the summary my
dating life not much to write about
pathetic right maybe that's why I love
spending time alone in these woods
chasing squirrels hunting ducks and
other young aware preys maybe my life is
too simple right now I don't know
interesting so do you live around here -
oh great atmosphere and nice ventilation
no need to paint the walls it's prime
real estate if I have any noisy
neighbors I usually just hunt them down
the only problem I have right now is
with this sewage it gets clogged up all
the hair yes since I shaved like twice a
day there's a lot of fur to get rid of
it's mostly annoying but hey that's mine
a problem exchange from our beautiful
cave mansion what a cave hey babe if
it's cool with you it's cool with me
Wow triple musashi I'm so glad you don't
mind me living in the cave I'm
independent and happy so what's wrong
with that right you've been nothing but
charming and understanding and only
slightly racist tonight so you know what
I want you to be the first guy welcome
into my cave it could be a bit humid at
first but you'll find it very warm
inside okay all right I'm trying to
imagine a situation where this isn't a
sexual innuendo I'm trying to imagine
one possible connotation but my brain is
struggling to comprehend this in any way
that's not a euphemism let's go Johnny I
can give you a massage with my sharp
claws Oh am i have the number one wing
matter what I have no idea you didn't do
a goddamn thing the whole time
whoo that's nice oh that's oh boy that's
nice
well that oh oh that's nice ooh oh
that's a nice one so each each of these
um interesting people give vastly
different massages this this massage is
nice but then gets intense from the what
I can only imagine is sharp claws
digging into my back okay got that one
Martha whoa duck oops hey I got a duck
that's nice don't know how I got that
but I got it I mean I got by dying
change your profile I'm gonna change my
profile I'm a winner baby just me
sorry nope Mayo I think I know what that
is I saw it in the trail a Janine
arginine for [ __ ] don't look at me to me
I'm too pretty I'm too pretty for all
y'all Oh massage random tip number 183
during a date at a fancy restaurant
stealthily urinate able dominance Johnny
is in a spacecraft in the middle of
nowhere
hi how are you oh do you so handsome
let's make babies here and whoa whoa
WAIS wait watch jackpot furniture
jackpot heck take what you can get am i
right okay I guess that was you see well
alright then
okay all right well see see what
oh it's pulsing oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god my repressed
childhood memories oh god okay anyway
let's try that again with less a little
less a little less insanity going on
here let's try it let's try that again
okay all right where are we oh yes my
bad I got too excited when I saw you my
name is Janine and this is my favorite
place on this planet yeah dark well you
don't like this place too good huh what
do you say to the big fat joke dude
spread it out this real place is
exquisite my damn do you like it I knew
you'd like it I fixed it all just for
this date so for you and you and you and
you alone I went through a lot of
trouble to get here - can I get your
water a cookie Lube or whatever you'd
like to ingest I want you to feel
comfortable since I need a I mean a lot
from you feeling good feeling great
let's go have fun this is gonna be a
restricted for cozy in here every night
is lovely out here and it's getting
better because you're here - took me a
while to get to you I want to make the
most of it yes yes yes yes I feel like I
travelled to galaxies just to be with
you I've been watching you for such a
long long long time
don't you feel we belong to now that
you're an adult I can finally use your
genes so kind - I need them to make
babies just right
your big strong I bet your genes aren't
do you you think I'm talking about your
pants aren't you oh never mind that gosh
you're so insufferable selfish selfish
selfish I want you to use me as pants
I'll be your pants oh never mind never
mind we can take things slow we have all
night you should be happy tonight
although I already know everything about
you
silly to keep chatting right
good but it really does smell weird oh
my gosh on second thought it does smell
kind of funny in here I'm sure I got rid
of that smell last week damn damn good
I'll be right back Johnny dear don't go
anywhere
Jane left through a weird liquid door
Johnny here's some ruckus under the
floor Janine it's cursing like a sailor
something's burning but the smell
disappeared we're glad that's gone now
smell aside what do you think about us I
mean are we gonna share our bodies our
genes our loved one f skids so bad don't
you just love children seeing them
running playing perpetuating a species
children are miracles we should totally
have something like how is it that you
don't find me attractive no no your
beauty is out of this world
oh you mean it if you find me pretty
then you must want me babies why though
why does there have to be a reason for
everything that's a nice Charlie Brown
phrase I mean I love you we're totally
soul mates right Oh
the truth is Johnny I want to reproduce
with you because you're so smart oh my
gosh you win I can't lie anymore
it goes I guess you deserve the real
truth well where I come from you know
it's complicated
needless to say I must bear strong
children to save my people
I need my dozen eggs fertilized by an
alpha male I'm sure you know people that
go through that right even so I won't
force you to do something you don't want
to I really really truly do care about
you but I really really truly hope you
can see my point of view but what are
you I'm the future mother of your
children of course I'm so happy you
understand my situation
Essam waste any more time you're gonna
need a lot of energy and you
but am I so exciting my armpits such a
nice girl you have a kind heart Johnny
what did you say to me what the [ __ ] did
you say to me what the [ __ ] okay well
try for triple intensity Mayo needs a
different okay I'm a great listener and
in contact with my feelings on Mayo like
that right Mayo Mayo yeah I thought so I
think I know what this is I think I've
seen this before
and I think it was in the trailer anyway
and I have a funny feeling about this
random fact number 79 during the 30s
Hollywood actors were not allowed to
kiss for longer than three seconds I
didn't know that is that true
[Music]
hi my name is mayo welcome to my
apartment make yourself at home I have a
chair somewhere at least I think I do
oh yeah yeah I know my apartment is an
armpit so messy oh hey may I offer you
something to drink anything will do I am
unusually thirsty okay here you go
Mayo give Johnny a glass of avoid
substance and some mint leaves
oh yeah I know I look a bit down sorry I
can't be a better host at the moment
this is I think this is made by the same
people that made my name is Mayo and if
you haven't seen my video on that
that's a [ __ ] Wild Ride I know I look
a bit down chaga can't be a better host
at the moment I was so very incredibly
lucky that you picked me on linger you
have a nice butt
maybe you don't want to hear about it
really no one should oh okay
I'm a great listener oh you will
well it goes it's just that feel like my
father is not out of me
you know that makes me seriously lose my
confidence so a few days ago this girl I
met left me it's really stupid so I kind
of put my own sexuality into question
I'm just confused now I don't know what
I want or Who I am anymore well let me
help you we started about talking about
your feelings well here goes sort of
been experimenting with myself my
sexuality different partners you know
I'll started when I try to his tight
Ricky made me feel very confident and
open the whole side of me I never knew
such a wild ride and I loved it whoa
mama whoa mama
keep going oh geez you're making me
blush now this is something I've never
told anyone so what happened is that I
experimented with different clothes
I felt wild in my leopard bikini about
Savage with my [ __ ]
doodlee after that I started getting
nude in public everything was great
until I got inside the zoo's monkey cage
needless to say I went to prison whoa
let me tell you I won't be wearing that
banana suit ever again
there's just meters it's steamy in here
oh boy
[Music]
oh boy but I'll keep going and I don't
know what to tell you I feel so confused
sometimes I feel like I'm playing catch
up with myself happily playing catch up
yeah catch up that's what I said so I
got wearing the bikinis that made me
feel confident with nothing or what
might elephant trousers but nothing it's
like like I suddenly lost my spark you
know I don't know what I want anymore
maybe you should need to wear the
clothes for someone who appreciates them
you think so
things can't be that simple can they
never been anyone that likes my elephant
razors well I really like putting
elephants on
Oh Johnny could it be you were the one I
was waiting for couldn't abandon I've
been alone with you inside sure and in
my dreams I've kissed your lid a
thousand times see you back since I did
my dorm hello hello is it me who hunted
my Peck sir open wide
you know just what to say and you know
just what to do and I want to tell you
so much
[Music]
damn Johnny key just open mega boobs
oh oh whoa all right bye van by mail
okay group gross play pro yeah you know
what pretty sure all right okay well
canvas what kind of a sushi nothing
nothing
oh you well that's lingering well that's
the lingering low Rumble hoose leaves an
aftertaste of mayo in my mouth
how much said this whole game down games
weird me out a little bit man that was a
lot that I haven't done yet boy
no nobody can handle this amount of
taste the white and oh I got a jar of
mayo so anyway that is at least the
first episode of mr. Musashi hilariously
that's the thing about this game is so
awkward and weird but also hilarious and
I like that in my jar of mayonnaise to
be awkward weird and then also make me
laugh and then massage my neck anyway so
thank you everybody so much for watching
uh let me know what you thought of this
game down the comments below no sexual
innuendos here kind of like a single
entendre not a double one but I don't
like it but I like the game I don't like
I don't like what the game does to me
but I like the game so thank you
everybody so much for watching and if
you want to see more of this let me know
in the comments below I might do a full
playthrough baby so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]